welcome back so we've been going through
this video progression summarizing the
chapters of this new roadmap document on
the potential impact of control in
solving some of the world's largest
societal scale challenges in the next
years and decades and this is the last
video at least for a little while kind
of summarizing the key takeaways and
recommendations after now that you've
seen these uh these chapters all the way
through this progression now we can kind
of zoom out and take away some of these
key recommendations and takeaways so I
thought it might be fun just to very
briefly go back through now that we've
seen this and kind of remind ourselves
what we've seen and that's always good
kind of learning pedagogy
so we started off with a very high level
introduction which is kind of the Duel
of this conclusion summary
recommendations
first make major kind of technical or
meaty chapter is chapter two societal
drivers that really sets the stage for
the entire road map so we've seen
throughout this entire progression that
all of these chapters are focused on
specifically solving societal scale
challenges that are facing all of
humanity things like you know Equitable
access to health care and you know
neurotechnology climate change autonomy
and self-driving cars really really big
societal scale
challenges and Technologies really
motivated in chapter two
the next chapter I really love the
progression of this the next chapter
chapter 3 talks about what is changing
in the broader technological landscape
at large that might allow control
theorists to do a better job of
addressing these societal scale
challenges things like you know the rise
of machine learning and big data that is
a societal scale technological Trend not
specific to control theory but it might
allow us as control theorists to do a
better job at addressing these societal
scale challenges Okay so we've set the
stage with what are the challenges what
are the new broad Technologies in the
world
chapter 4 emerging methodologies is
really now focusing back on what are the
emerging control methodologies how do we
use these technological Trends to do a
better job of control theory so that we
can address larger scale societal
challenges okay so a very natural and
nice progression going from motivations
you know what is the Big Challenge why
is it important to you know what's new
what's changed now to what can we do
about it as control theorists this is
how I write you know papers and
proposals I think it's a very logical
way of of uh progressing from motivation
to what are the tools we can solve them
with
and then chapter five very naturally now
that we have laid the stage for what
types of control methodologies are
emerging to solve these problems how do
we actually get those into societal
scale industrial scale deployment and
that's what chapter five is all about is
how do you develop infrastructure so
that you can test new methods so you can
validate them and so that you can
eventually you know iron out all of the
all of the the wrinkles get rid of all
of the bugs so that you can actually
deploy these Technologies at scale you
know if we're going to deploy uh control
theory solutions for autonomy and
self-driving cars or at every node in
the power grid they had better be
rigorously validated on very
sophisticated validation Benchmark
problems okay so this makes a lot of
sense
now the next chapter is super important
to me and I think it makes a lot of
sense if we actually want to be doing
this in the next years and decades we
need to be educating the workforce of
the future the next generation of people
who are actually going to be using these
emerging methodologies and actually you
know getting them ready for for societal
scale deployment and so that is the
focus of chapter six is education how do
we get
control theory in the hands of everybody
in engineering and in science and how do
we tell policy makers what are the tools
we have in engineering and how we can
help how do we educate broadly uh the
world so that we have this robust kind
of Workforce who knows what the
capabilities are in this field
and then chapter seven again one of the
things I really really like about this
roadmap is that they could have stopped
there and that would be a natural place
to stop but they didn't chapter seven is
uh this very important threat and it
actually goes throughout this entire
roadmap document which I think is
important is this idea of the ethical
and fairness this kind of equity lens of
how you develop and deploy control
Solutions it's not just about solving a
numerical problem or stabilizing you
know some system there are other aspects
that we need to be optimizing over in
our cost functions there is a human
element and you know we've seen for
example that if you deploy solar panels
to uh you know augment the the power
grid to build in renewable energy to
solve you know some of these big
societal challenges like climate change
that can have different effects on
different populations right so there
might be an inequity and how that
goodness is is spread across a
population and so I think it's really
really important that this chapter is
here so that we start thinking about our
control Solutions through the lens of
their societal impacts and start being
very explicit if you don't write down a
cost function that includes Equity or
fairness or ethics you are making a
choice by omitting that and I think it's
really important for us to understand
that okay and I'm just very pleased that
that is a thread that goes throughout
this document okay so that is the the
high level summary and and if you
actually go to chapter eight it's fairly
short which I like it's very focused on
actual recommendations so for example
chapter two one of the biggest kind of
largest sections in this document has
these five subsections and these are you
know very concise very pointed
recommendations for each of these uh
each of these topics so very quick read
actually a nice place to start by
potentially all of the chapters have
these nice abstract kind of summary
takeaways and this is also a nice kind
of key takeaway
so things like you know in climate
change climate change is going to be
something that we as humans are going to
need to engineer solutions for you know
we we've seen just in 2023 this uh you
know quite abrupt deviation from data uh
in terms of you know the North Atlantic
Sea surface temperature we of course
know that this is something we need to
engineer solutions for there are key
takeaways in this recommendation is you
know focusing us on these challenges
similarly
um chapter three one of our larger
chapters has you know four large
sections so each of these has a key
takeaway again I'm kind of focusing on
one of my key takeaways is we better not
ignore machine learning and Big Data
this is you know one of the most
powerful and transformative tools we
humans have
um you know ever really and we need to
be addressing this head-on how do we
incorporate this into control theory and
how do we use this to its fullest
uh chapter four again emerging
Technologies how do we use these new uh
technological Trends in control theory
um you know maybe I'm biased because
again I do work in learning and control
but there are key takeaways um of how we
actually need to be bringing these
together and leveraging the power of
both of these methodologies and and so
on and so forth you know chapters five
six and seven are a little bit shorter
but they each have very important
takeaways that you can read about here
that kind of summarize after reading
this roadmap what you should have taken
away
um this is actually a really cool
um video that I received from one of the
editors
um Professor Johansen that essentially
describes this challenge of autonomy and
Fleet kind of efficiency gains that you
can achieve with coordinated control of
vehicles so essentially you know if you
have different trucking routes in
Germany you want those trucks to be able
to form platoons this is more energy
efficient it cuts down on greenhouse gas
emissions it's more resilient and robust
in a lot of ways and so I like this
example because this kind of ties
together a lot of those different themes
throughout the chapters of this roadmap
but also shows you know if you are going
to develop a control theory solution it
really has to be robust it really has to
work at scale and it actually really can
solve some very relevant societal skill
challenges you know we burn a lot of
fuel we spend a lot of energy moving
goods from one place to another and
there's a lot of benefits to that but
you know we could be doing it better we
we have new technology at our disposal
to do this better so again very cool
video this is I think about three or
four minutes I'm not going to show you
everything I'll try to put a link
um in in the the description below but
again just key takeaways for every
chapter here so in my kind of zooming
out conclusion again I want to uh
acknowledge the excellent uh work by the
three editors who brought all of this
together and also the wonderful
co-authors that contributed to the
various subsections and chapters in this
roadmap it really is an amazing group of
people
and I think you know hopefully this gets
people excited that there are you know
we don't just bury our head in the sand
when there are challenges what do
engineers do we try to solve those
problems okay we make a plan and we we
solve them and control theory is one of
the best tools that we have available to
change a dynamical system as it's
evolving in time so we have time we
should be control in the system all
right I'm Steve Brunton thank you